yesterday the u.s supreme court took up
oral arguments in an antitrust lawsuit
filed by a group of
former college football players led by
former west virginia running back sean
alston
arguing that the ncaa in and of itself
is an antitrust violation insofar as it
creates limits on what can be offered to
players and therefore there's no
competition among schools
to get the players to go there you don't
have any extras that you can offer for
this guy any extras you can offer for
that person it's all limited it's all
capped the argument is that that
eliminates competition it violates the
antitrust laws that's the core of the
argument chris they were successful at
the lower court but not to the point
where the lower court said that the
players can be paid it's other benefits
over and above the standard room board
tuition
fees
and snacks
there's more things you can offer that
the ncaa says no that's what it's all
about and the oral arguments yesterday
there were a lot of questions aggressive
questioning of the ncaa
aggressive questioning of the plaintiffs
but reason to think that that the
reckoning could be here because the
argument is and this is a weird argument
that the ncaa
believes that the consumers of college
sports
want the players to be amateurs
i don't think the consumers of college
sports give a crap about that i know i
don't right yeah i mean how convenient
of a thought that is oh wait they they
the consumer wants them to be amateurs
so therefore we don't have to pay them
we don't want to pay the i mean of
course they don't want to pay i mean
what a bs argument that is
that's all there is to that i mean
that's stupid i would i would be
watching you know the final four if it
was the team that was oh they don't do
anything and they don't pay their
players and if it was another team where
they were handing out gold chains and
five thousand dollars in cash every day
i'd go well i can't wait to watch this
one team's clean the other one's paying
money this is gonna be awesome let's see
who wins i mean come on that's that's
bull crap that's a horrible argument the
ncaa's argument and as a whole is bs to
me and you know the one thing i found
intriguing about it mike and i know you
know more about this than i did but i
read a little bit about it
some of those
the questions uh from some of the
justices i mean i i found those a little
bit you know attention
seeking for me as far as oh wow okay
they're i mean you know clarence thomas
i believe he asked something about it
right there was another comment that of
course jumped out to me to that seemed
like they were
really questioning the ncaa
and clarence thomas has a reputation for
rarely if ever asking any questions
during oral arguments so when he speaks
it is very noteworthy
he said yeah what do you say when when
he questioned the ncaa he asked whether
that that in the name of amateur
sports the ncaa also tries to limit the
compensation for coaches which is a hell
of a question big question right yeah if
it's all about amateurs and it's amazing
well then they all should be amateurs
that's right this should be a guy who
who you know he he sells insurance by
day
and then on the weekends he coaches the
college football team if you're an
amateur right instead of because see
this is ultimately why the ncaa is
fighting as folks they don't want to
have to blow up their budgets and factor
in a gigantic new line item consisting
of paying the workforce
it's a lot easier to balance your budget
sheet
when you don't have to
pay your workers you're paying your
coaches you're paying your
administrators you're paying your
president you're paying for this that
and the other thing they all have these
opulent facilities because they don't
have to pay the players it's easier to
do that it's easier to make ends meet
when you don't have to pay the players
that's what this is all about and they
want to continue that model for as long
as they can and chris i think they
recognized 10 years ago the ox is going
to get gourd at some point they're going
to have to face their reckoning and
every year that goes by that they don't
is gravy to them at some point that
reckoning is coming and they're just
gonna fight and fight and fight spending
on lawyers the money they don't have to
spend on their players and hold it off
as long as they can i think that's what
they're doing and i hope at some point
these players will get fair compensation
for the
billions that they generate that's right
i mean billions and you know
i know there's the people with arguments
about oh you're getting free boarding
and free school and all that
yeah okay i get that
but a lot of these schools
they're not that expensive right now you
know i see like i saw comments on like
the bottom of the pro football talk just
there where so many people are like the
first mistake well i know people realize
what it costs to go to college yes we do
realize and it's not as expensive as
some of these state schools that are
awesome at football as you'd think it's
not and it's not apples to apples to
what some of these players are
delivering you know for that school so
that's not a good argument and in
college football specifically
compared to the other sports players
sell in college football you know one we
have legit nfl stars who are playing for
three years they have to be there three
years so now you have those stars that
are there that's different than college
basketball where it's one and done and
or they don't even go to college or
whatever else they avoid it and go
overseas something like that you know
that's different so no people can't
latch onto that one and done you can
latch on to a three and done guy and
within college football too there's a
real culture there of
just college football you don't
necessarily need to be an nfl star to be
a college star you know guys like tim
tebow his j his jersey's going to sell
forever down there in florida no matter
what he did or didn't do in the nfl and
there's a lot of other college players
that are just like that where there's no
nfl stardom but they are associated with
that school they won a heisman or
national championships at that school
and that school is still selling their
jersey number to this day
and there's nothing to be getting back
or getting gotten back for the players
that makes no sense
well i i've got two points to make based
upon what you said first of all anytime
i hear that free education stuff you
have to understand
it's not the retail value
of the education you know colleges and
and i'm sure i'm going to get plenty of
very pleasant
reasonable non-hostile emails today but
i firmly believe this colleges are like
a jewelry store where they mark
everything up the anybody who's playing
paying full price that's right for
college is a sucker right because all
you got to do is show up and they give
you a scholarship hey you have the
showing up scholarship what's your name
oh that's your name you get the you told
us your name scholarship right um
you know
let's see uh do you have a high school
diploma oh you get the high school
diploma scholarship so i it's it's it's
all inflated so everyone feels like
they're getting a deal and the reality
is how much does it really cost
to say
we've got one more person who's going to
attend class or is the case may be not a
ten class one more person we have to put
in a dorm one more person we have to go
feed at the communal food trough where
they're buying food by the the truckload
how expensive is that to let one more
person go eat to let one more person
sleep in a cot to let one more person
have you know pretzels and peanuts at 10
o'clock at night so
it's not an equal trade that's the
problem and you're talking about the
abilities of these individuals the
sacrifices they put in for the time they
devote to it and the risk they take of
injury both short term and long term so
that's one side of it where when
somebody says they're getting a free
education i say get the hell out of here
with that argument and here's the other
reason i say get the hell out of here
with that argument
most of these guys and i'm focusing on
college football players they've been
cream of the crop their whole life best
of the best when they played youth
football best of the best when they
played middle school best of the best
when they played high school they're
being recruited by a major college to go
play there in their mind they're going
to play in the nfl they don't care about
the numbers they don't care about the
percentages they don't care about how
few jobs are available because there's
only 32 teams not 150
college teams but 32 nfl teams they
don't care about that they've always
risen to the top i'm gonna keep rising
to the top right and i'd go to the nfl
right now if i could but i can't so what
am i gonna do i'm gonna go to one of
these colleges and i'm gonna major in
football and chris the nfl and the nfl
players association and and that's part
of the irony in this jeffrey kessler
who's been the long time outside counsel
for the nflpa is the lawyer for this
antitrust case pushing the argument
against the ncaa the nflpa is complicit
in this
three-year
rule that
forces guys to go to college football
right you've the nfl and the union
are part of the problem here folks and
i'm only speaking the truth they're part
of the problem because they force guys
to go provide free labor for three years
and then they pick the best of the best
after those three years and bring them
into the nfl yeah i i hear you now i
that that's a deep conversation uh
because there is also
and and you know i guess this would work
itself out but
you know again
it's rare that a freshman or something
like that can you so what somebody wants
to use a draft pick on freshmen let them
that's right that's right they're old
enough to go fight and die on foreign
soil they're old enough to go to the nfl
all right that's all that's a bullcrap
argument i'm not mad at you no i know
but people make that argument right and
the nfl makes that argument oh these are
these underdeveloped bodies and if a
team wants to draft a guy let him draft
a guy that's what i was going to say
it's going to police itself you don't
need that rule right teams will go wait
he's a freshman he's immature he's not
physically mature we're not he's not
ready yet okay now the bad thing about
that is just would that would the ncaa
now let that guy go back to school
that's that's the thing where that i
think needs to get fixed a little too if
you're going to do that because you know
that that no they won't they won't but
they won't because they you hey you made
your choice i made a choice so future
guys won't do that i know that's stupid
that also needs to change to go to go
along with it now the last thing i
wanted to ask you what was the other
justice was that justice kavanaugh who
made a quote you know that yeah oh yeah
he had he had a a very a fairly uh
powerful quote he said he said uh
basically aren't you exploiting these
athletes aren't you using your argument
to to not pay them as a way to just
exploit college athletes i mean he hit
the nail on the head yeah he gets it and
i understand he entered the supreme
court under a you know significant
controversy that captured the national
attention for several weeks but now he's
out one of those seats and he used his
voice yesterday to ask questions that i
think need to be asked yeah it's about
it's about getting free labor don't we
all want free labor if we can get it
life's a hell of a lot easier if you
have a workforce you don't have to pay
but the question is is it right and then
the question is is it legal and then and
the ncaa is going to find out you know
usually what happens is by june that's
when the term ends there'll be a cycle
every week there'll be two or three
opinions that pop out there'll be a
decision at some point by the time the
term ends in june mid to late june and
we'll know whether or not the ncaa can
keep doing this or whether they're going
to have to start making other benefits
available or more accurately
eliminating
that rule
that prevents the schools
from
really recruiting it's going to be more
than just nick saban showing up and
sweet talking someone it's going to be
you got to come with something more yeah
right than than the standard
undergraduate education to get my son to
sign a letter of intent to go to your
school yeah no i mean it it might come
to that you're right you know i don't
know what they do maybe they figure out
some sort of salary cap for these
college colleges like hey you can you
can only spend this much cash to buy
players this year and i trust violation
yeah that's another antitrust violation
okay
yeah now now again the the lower court
the federal appeals court
focused only on
education related benefits like graduate
tuition yeah other equipment and things
that currently aren't allowed to be
provided like musical instruments if
there's a a college athlete who's a
music major and
currently the ncaa says well you can't
you know you can't give them the guitar
or the saxophone or whatever well now
you may be able to they haven't crossed
the bridge yet of actual payments
but the whole idea is and the only
reason the nfl gets away with the salary
cap is because it's a unionized
workforce applying to multiple different
businesses if there and this was the
whole antitrust argument from 1987
through 93 it was the argument they made
in 2011. once you take the union out of
the equation
any effort to limit what one business is
going to pay its employees an effort
that is the result of collective action
by multiple businesses is an anti-trust
violation and so
uh it it potentially ends up being open
season chris
where
what whatever someone will pay
is whatever
they are able to negotiate uh by way of
a salary or whatever benefits and that's
the way you know let's say there's some
so the next tim tebow
that that's the way you can
you know you can uh win the recruiting
war how much money you're going to show
up with and when you look at all the
money that college football makes the
money's there there would be huge
disparities between the best players and
the worst but there is in the nfl yeah
no you're right there is i mean there's
a really a part of me as you explained
this i'd love to see it i really would i
think it'd be kind of fun you know you'd
probably have some schools that go no
wait we really have a you know a top
flight education here and we're not
gonna like notre dame they might be one
that doesn't bend their rules here they
are this is what we are we're notre dame
right and then it's some other new age
school who's paying players and doing
all that i think that could be fun for
college football i do but
please something i mean currently this
hey chris there's only there's only two
or three teams that matter now there's
three it's not like it's gonna get worse
you're that's what i want you're right i
mean it's ohio state alabama or clemson
like hey wait this just in one of those
three teams is gonna be in the national
championship game next year maybe both
and one of them's gonna win it like okay
and who will that fourth be will it be
notre dame will be lsu i don't know but
if those three are going to be there
you're right so
i don't know if it does change a whole
lot but either way all these arguments
people use to go against the players and
everything it's just not right you know
i i again i know there's things that are
positive there and all of that type of
stuff but you know there's too many
players like we've talked about even in
my day where yeah it's it's scrounging
for money to make you know make meals
work during the weekend and things like
that and that just should never be and
that should not like you said these
schools are making hundreds of millions
60 70 million a year on their football
team and here's the other thing that
gets lost in this too you know you
talked about it a little you know a lot
of these guys you know you're going to
college football in these major programs
because you think you're an nfl football
player we always hear the stories about
the guy who got hurt but got drafted
still and was successful in the nfl what
we don't realize is how many guys there
are that
oh you know he might have not been a
star in the nfl
but he was going to make it to the nfl
and he ruined his knee or he ruined his
shoulder or he had a neck injury and
that's the other thing people forget
about this too so now
this guy or a handful of guys from a
four years of being in college he's put
everything on the line for that school
and everything like that he's got no
money
and he was going to be an nfl football
player but now he's got a career ending
injury and he'll never capitalize on his
talents and really what he was maybe put
here on god's green earth to do
the best which is play football he can't
do that now and nor does he have money
and that that to me pisses me off too
best example tyrone pro throw remember
that name yeah i do remember that name
alabama star receiver right played in
alabama catastrophic leg injury and uh
uh never made it the nfl yeah uh and
you know a few of those guys
i remember watching
i think it was hard knocks one year
my wife and i were watching it when it
was the bengals and there was a guy who
tore an achilles tendon this is a pro
player tore the achilles tent and he's
devastated you know crying talking to
his parents talking to the coaching
staff and
and and my wife said to me
you know
college athletes get these same injuries
and they're not they're not getting paid
it's like right
they're not getting paid and they're
subject to these same kinds of injuries
that can be that devastating and and so
i think for a lot of people at a
visceral level
once you pierce through the free
education bullcrap
um they understand what's going on and
here's here's here's the bottom line
the people who are making more money
than they should
will make less
the administrators the presidents the
coaches
that money is going to get redistributed
they don't want it to happen yes and and
the jobs are going to get more difficult
for the people who have to balance this
budget when you have to pay the players
well too bad
that's what you have to do professional
teams do it
and these amateur teams shouldn't get
away with it yeah no i'm right you're
right tell me out of the blue we have to
go to break come on pete where were
coaches too just the last thing they get
paid at the major programs better than
the nfl coaches yeah the head coach
might not make as much as the elite nfl
hooked but the assistants
they make really good ridiculous yes
ridiculous
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports